hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll today's big idea is something
that builds on the last couple of videos
where we talked about quantum mechanics
and then entanglement today we're going
to talk about fields in particular
quantum fields right quantum field
theory as it's typically known and
what's going on here is we've already
mentioned the idea of fields we talked
about the electric field the magnetic
field the gravitational field very
briefly we didn't go into any details
about them now we're going to be
applying the rules of quantum mechanics
to this idea of fields so far we've been
talking about quantum mechanics it's
more or less been in the context of a
particle or a couple of particles or a
spin or something like that but the big
news is that according to modern physics
the world is made of quantum fields and
that should be a little bit puzzling at
first glance because we already started
with a particle and then we quantize it
and found out that it had wave-like
properties right the electron is a
particle you treat it quantum
mechanically it's a wave function but we
think that in experiments in nature
there are also particle-like properties
right the electron leaves a track in a
bubble chamber or a cloud chamber it
looks like it has a trajectory as if it
were a particle but if we start with a
field and then we quantize it so we
promote it to having a wave function how
in the world are we going to get
particles out of that that is going to
be the major idea that we try to pursue
today so first let's talk about what we
mean when we just say fields a field we
already said is something that has a
value everywhere in space a value of
some sort or another at each point in
space and when I say a value that's
gonna be a lot of the tricky part going
forward so weak it's easy enough to draw
space okay and then a field is basically
at every point in space there's some
mathematical object representing the
value of that field so in the simplest
case here's a point X we'll put a little
loops let me draw it a little bit
more effectively their ex a little
vector sign over it means the
three-dimensional vector that locates us
in space X and associated with that
point there is a value of the field Phi
of X so the Greek letter Phi is often
used for the simplest kind of fields in
quantum field theory but it could be
something more complicated so what it
means in this case is that Phi is just a
number
so if Phi if the field is just a number
at each point then we say we have a
scalar field we talked about scalars
before as numbers you could multiply
things by the example of a scalar field
the classic example the only known
example in nature of a fundamental
scalar field is the Higgs boson took us
a while to find it
2012 but we've done it there it is there
are scalar fields in nature the number
could be a complex number or it could be
a collection of complex numbers but it's
nothing that changes as you change
space-time itself as you rotate or look
at different ways whereas if the field
equals a vector then guess what you have
a vector field
look at that I wrote scalar nature
because I have still not developed the
ability to write and talk and I said the
word nature so you know that there are
vector fields in nature because you
heard of the electric field the magnetic
field at every point there is not just a
number there's a little arrow
representing the electric field vector
or the magnetic field vector in fact
there's both this is the crucial thing
that separates classical fields right
now we're just being classical we
haven't quantized anything yet the
reason why classical field theory is
different from quantum mechanics where
there's still a wave function right is
because when you have many particles you
don't have many wave functions
overlapping you have one wave function
for everything
when you have a set of classical fields
at every point there are a bunch of
different classical fields so literally
at every point in space the modern field
theorist says in the classical limit at
least there is a value for the Higgs
field there's a
for the electric feel the value for the
magnetic field value for the
gravitational field and also as we will
see there are fields for all the matter
particles like electrons and neutrinos
and quarks and all those things they all
have fields with values at every point
so we will get into the different kinds
of fields right the vector fields
there's there's more than just scalars
and vectors but those are probably the
ones you're most interested in in when
we talked about the potential wave
physics could have gone in the early
20th century if quantum académie
mechanics hadn't been the reality we
could have imagined a view where
particles were matter and fields were
forces okay
so classically there is that dichotomy
that particles and fields were playing
different roles quantum mechanically
fields are everything and that's going
to be part of what we try to understand
here so let's think about how to
quantize this idea right this idea of a
classical field we want to quantize it
I'm using the word quantize very loosely
here if you read quantum mechanics books
they will try to give you a cookbook
recipe to go from a classical theory to
a quantum mechanical theory it's a
little bit misleading when they do that
in fact because there's no one-to-one
map between classical theories and
quantum theories there are classical
theories that have more than one quantum
counter part in other words there's
their classical theories that are the
limit of more than one very
different-looking quantum mechanical
theory and vice-versa you can have a
quantum mechanical theory that has more
than one kind of classical limit so
there's no immediate correspondence
between classical theories and quantum
theories nevertheless because we human
beings are so sort of intuitive in terms
of classical physics but not so much in
quantum physics physicists usually start
with taking a classical theory and
turning it into a quantum theory in some
way that's what we're gonna do with
quantum field theory but we're not doing
any systematic way I'm sort of going to
tell you the answer is in various ways
try to motivate them along the way so
classical particles just remind us what
we did have a position let's say X right
remember that and then we invented
quantum mechanical versions of particles
and they had a wavefunction so quantum
particles have a wavefunction you may
notice that I'm being a little bit
inconsistent because I already said that
there is only one wave function of the
universe so I really shouldn't say that
a quantum particle has a wave function
but in terms of the entanglement that we
talked about last time
there can be situations and there very
often are situations where a single
particle is not entangled with anything
else in the rest of the world in that
case it makes perfect sense to talk
about the wave function of that particle
so as long as we keep our wits about us
there's nothing wrong with talking about
the wave function of a single particle
or even two different wave functions for
two different particles as long as they
are not entangled which can often be the
case so the wave function looks like
capital sine as a function of X in other
words for each possible position that
the particle could be observed to have
we assign a complex number that complex
number is capital psy of X and we call
it the amplitude so this is yet another
way in which we are being a little
sloppy when I write psy as a function of
X usually what you have in mind is the
whole function for all the different X's
if you pick out a point sometimes you
will call that you know X star or X
nought or something like that and writes
I of X star that's fine so
mathematically we think of the wave
function psy as a map from positions all
the possible positions you could observe
the particle to have two amplitudes and
then the amplitude be a complex number
you square that complex number to get
the probability of actually observing
the particle to be at that position were
you to measure it and to be super
Matthew about it what is the set of all
positions that a particle could
well we're not being super physic see
about it so don't think about you know
string theory and extra dimensions in
everyday life the set of positions is
three dimensional so this is our three
where our means the real numbers so this
is the three dimensional version of the
real numbers or you have three
dimensions telling you which direction
you're moving in so this is a three
dimensional vector space the set of all
positions in flat Euclidean
three-dimensional space and then they
get mapped to the complex numbers a
single copy of the complex numbers so
you give me three real numbers that
tells me where we are in space the
position X and then I get this is X and
then I get the complex number sigh of X
single complex number and I will square
it if I observe where the particle is
the probability of seeing the particle
at X is equal to the magnitude of sigh
of x squared and if you don't remember I
think I did mention this very briefly if
a complex number sign equals a plus I B
where I equals the square root of minus
1 then the absolute value of size
squared which is the thing that is the
probability is just a squared plus B
squared so it's always a non-negative
number because it's the sum of two
squares and a and B are both real
numbers themselves as the I that is the
complex unit that makes the combination
a plus IB be a complex number okay so
this story as a whole is what we want to
generalize to this set of quantum fields
to the situation where we have quantum
field instead of having a position that
we can observe but we'll have for a
field is an entire field configuration
that we can observe okay so let's just
tell the story again but Ella for fields
start with classical fields and a
classical field has a configuration
which is to say a value of the field at
every point in space so Phi for example
of X would be the
set of all values of vital X's that's
the configuration of the field that's
one particular configuration the field
could be in okay so I have to say this
looks like a wave function right I write
5x here I write psy of X up here
they look like similar kinds of things
but they're really conceptually very
very different sigh the wave function is
the thing that you use to get the
probabilities if you added more
particles in you would not add more size
you just add more X's into the arguments
for sy whereas this is a classical field
which means that it has equations of
motion it would have a Hamiltonian if
you like they told you what energy it
had it could have an action and you
could minimize the action to find what
the equations of motion were but you
could observe it in principle as
accurately as you like there's no sense
in which Phi of X is sort of secretly
encoding some observational outcomes it
just is its value and it can be observed
as a classical field okay sadly the
world is not run by classical field
theory it's run by quantum field theory
but this is the idea you have in mind
when you talk about classical fields
they look notationally like quantum wave
functions but conceptually they're a
very different thing okay so what
happens if you try to turn it into a
quantum field well quantum fields are
going to be things where there is a wave
function but the wave function is not a
function of position in space it's a
function of field configurations all
throughout space so they have a wave
function capital sigh which will write
with square brackets as a function of
some particular field configuration 5x
so what we imagine here never actually
happens in real life what we imagine
here is the thing that we're measuring
is not the value of Phi at some point X
but simultaneously measure all
throughout space what the value of Phi
is this number psy is a complex number
attached to every specific configuration
if I can have throughout the world okay
and then we attach a complex number to
that square it to get the probability so
this 5x is a field configuration just
SuperDuper explicit about this
throughout all of space and this sigh is
the complex amplitude associated with
that particular field configuration so
in other words in quantum field theory
you have a wave function of a wave a
wave function of a field that is
stretching out all throughout the
universe rather than just the wave
function of a single particle and then
psy squared versailles is a function of
v x is the probability of observing or
measuring the field to have the
configuration 5x it's beginning to seem
hard my field theory right because we've
already had to imagine doing this
observation of a field all throughout
space which we can't actually imagine
doing in the real world but conceptually
there it is now in a real working
quantum field theories would imagine in
fact observing the field point by point
at different locations or in different
regions of space and you can use this
wave function of the large can field
configuration to calculate the
probability of getting different
outcomes at different points in space
but again conceptually this is the thing
that is the the center of the universe
the actual description of the universe
in quantum field theory so to say that
in Mathew words because we like to say
it both in English and in more mathy
words to be math you about it let let's
invent some notation here let capital F
of R 3 R 3 is just space
three-dimensional space the real line
times itself 3 times let F of R 3 be the
set of maps from R 3 to R that's suppose
to be an arrow there that's supposed to
be our okay
so we're imagining in particular to make
our lives easy that 5x our field is a
real scalar field so at every point it's
just a number it's just a real number
there are also fields that are complex
or multi valued or vectors or whatever
we're just imagining it's a real scalar
field so this R 3 represents space and
this R represents the value of the field
so this is X and this is 5 X so f of R 3
is the set of all field configurations
the set of all maps from R 3 to R and
then sigh the wave function is basically
a map from F of R 3 to the complex
numbers
it's a map that says you give me a
particular field configurational
throughout space I'll give you a complex
amplitude okay now sometimes
notationally you will hear this sigh as
a function of a field configuration
referred to as a wave functional because
sometimes when you go from finite
dimensional vector spaces like r3 right
like the positions X to infinite
dimensional vector spaces like f of r3
this by the way is an infinite
dimensional vector space sometimes they
think of elements of infinite
dimensional vector spaces as functions
and functions of functions as
functionals
this is the word that is used so
sometimes we use we use the word wave
functional for this but you know what
usually in quantum mechanics we do not
make big distinctions between finite
dimensional and infinite dimensional
vector spaces we just say it's the wave
function so I'm just gonna say it's the
wave function this is the wave function
for set of quantum fields ok so again
this seems hoof seems a little bit
complicated well more particularly it's
not the complication that worries us
what worries us of what might be
worrying you is we take this field which
is already not very part of
and make a wavefunction of it which is
not particle II either how in the world
are we supposed to say that this
represents our universe which seems to
be full of particles at least when we
observe them that's gonna be the tricky
part okay how do we get particles out of
this it's easy enough to say that we go
around assigning complex amplitudes to
every possible field configuration but
let's see it in action let's actually
get some work out of it okay so consider
the simplest possible field theory not
just a real scalar field but remember
these fields have dynamics they have
equations of motion and so when you tell
me I have a real valued scalar field or
I have a real valued vector field or a
complex field or whatever you're not
done telling me what the field is you
have to give me its equation right you
have to give me the way it evolves does
it interact with other fields just
interact with itself etc so the simplest
possible thing is to consider a non
interacting field a field that doesn't
interact with other fields or even with
itself in a way that'll make precise in
just a second and the technical term we
use here not very technical is free so
this is not free in the in the sense of
free beer this is free in the sense of
it's free to do whatever it once it's
not interacting it's not being bumped
into okay it's like you know free from
slavery you're not free from paying for
your dinner so this is a non interacting
free field and it's a scalar field a
real scalar field etc okay so let me in
fact let's mention let's imagine it just
in one dimension okay so here is let me
do that again
cuz I'm gonna want to do it twice here
is space X and here's the value of the
field we're thinking classically for a
moment here so let's you can do it
another color to make it stand out the
field is zero most places but there's a
little bump in it here and zero there's
a little bump in it there okay and this
bump is moving to the right this bump is
moving to the left and we will label
this bump bump a and bump B maybe even
though I'm not gonna be able to draw it
very effectively maybe bump a has
particular Wiggles and bumpy has some
particular Wiggles for a free field you
can imagine that those Wiggles can
maintain their shape to some extent and
then what's gonna happen over time is
that as a moves this way B moves that
way it will evolve into a new
configuration and the point of being a
free field is they will just go right
through each other these two bumps these
two perturbations these two excitation
Zoar whatever you want to call them in
the free scalar field do not interact
with each other so after some time what
you're gonna see is a field
configuration it looks like this that's
B and that's a so B is still moving that
way a still moving that way and despite
my poor drawing skills they're supposed
to be more or less unaffected by having
gone through each other okay it may be
that they're both individually waving up
and down but they're not affecting each
other so that's a simple example that we
can think about it's a sensible starting
place for our investigation and so we're
gonna consider the quantum theory of a
free scalar field that's that's our job
but we're gonna show how it gets us to
particles somehow so remember that any
field configuration and the field
Commissioner is the function of space a
real valued function of space okay so
any function remember when we talked
about Fourier transforms or Fourier
analysis any function can be written as
a sum of sine waves essentially sine
waves with different amplitudes and
different wavelengths I use the word
amplitude there it means something plea
different different heights and
different wave lengths so any function
can be written as a sum of sine waves
and what I mean by sine waves is sort of
the most general notion of a sine wave
just a wave that goes up and down with a
constant period or a constant frequency
if you want to call it it could be a
cosine just as well but sine waves is
that is the general term that we use
here and this is the Fourier transform
and I'm just stating it I'm not gonna
prove it I'm not gonna give examples you
just need to remember this fact okay you
don't understand this fact that's fine
but it's a fact
to be able to say back to me can any
function be written as the sum of sine
waves yes it can and uniquely we can do
you give me a function you give me some
field configuration I can figure out
exactly the combination of sine waves
that would reproduce it so I start with
something that is some arbitrary
function right doing something like that
that is my 5x as a function of X and I
can write it as a sum of things that
look like some long wavelength mode plus
some things that look like a little
shorter wavelength plus some things that
look like an even shorter wavelengths
plus dot dot if I pick correctly and
there's a mathematically correct way of
doing this like pick correctly the
different wavelengths and the different
heights for these sine waves I can add
them together to make any function I
want and it's absolutely unique and it
is reversible I can go backwards and go
from the sine waves to the function I go
from the sign from the function to the
sine waves we call each one of these a
mode of the field okay a Fourier mode
one of the contributions in this way of
thinking to how to describe that
particular function now just as a note
just because you're gonna say well I've
drawn these pictures in one dimension
what about three dimensions so there's a
three-dimensional version of this okay
three spatial dimension illusion it's
hard to draw a sine wave and oscillating
wave but you can visualize that you can
visualize for example a sound wave right
you've ever visualized a sound wave
moving through space there's a plane in
which it's more dense air and then a
plane flips right next to that in which
the air is less dense and then more
dense and then less dense and these
vibrations and density are what make a
sound wave so we will sort of
conceptualize a plane wave as they're
called in three dimensions as exactly
that sort of a set of planes moving in
some direction okay so this is all three
dimensions of space X Y Z
and there's a vector k k is called
cleverly the wave vector and the wave
vector says what direction the things
going in k also says let me see if i can
get this right yeah k also tells us the
wavelength so the wavelength here is the
difference between one peak and one
other peak and we call it lambda
traditionally so these planes that i've
drawn are supposed to be where the
function in three dimensions has a peak
remember it's a sinusoidal function
going up and down and in between the
planes it gets to be a trough or then a
peak again and so the wavelength lambda
is just the distance the number of
centimeters or whatever in between two
peaks and k is related to the wave
vector in the following way or sorry
lambda the wavelength is weight related
to the wave vector by lambda equals 2pi
divided by the length or the magnitude
of k okay one of these ubiquitous two
pies that appears in physics so what
this means all you need to know forget
about the two pies I don't remember
where they go all the time what do you
need to know is a big wave vector
corresponds to a small wavelength and
vice versa so the wave vector contains
almost all the information you need to
know about to reconstruct the plane wave
this is called a plane wave because of
exactly what it looks like bunch of
planes traveling waving and the other
thing is of course you need the height
of the wave so the if we just draw a
cross section and we draw a sine wave
then lambda the wavelength is the
distance between two peaks or two
troughs and let's call it h to be the
height and I will warn you ahead of time
I'm gonna have trouble remembering that
because the actual word that scientists
use to be to refer to the height of a
sine wave is the amplitude of the wave
but that's a use of the word amplitude
that has nothing to do with quantum
mechanics it's just a synonym for height
and so since I've already told you that
amplitude
the complex number that you square to
get the probability of observing
something ie a certain value of the
wavefunction I don't want to reuse the
word amplitude for the height of a sine
wave so let's just call it H the height
okay and I'll try to you all try to
remember that this this will be my job
to remember that so just like in one
dimension every single function can be
written as a sum of sine waves
appropriately chosen in three dimensions
every single function can be written as
a sum of plane waves and the plane wave
will be specified by the wave vector K
pointing and giving you the wavelength
and also the height the size of the wave
so given any field configuration three
dimensions I can write it as a sum of
plane waves and I call these once again
molds the different modes are each mode
has a wavelength and it has a direction
given by the wave vector okay now also
true is that each mode has an energy
there's an energy for each mode for a
plane wave and there's different way
that's different contributions just like
a particle moving in a potential has a
kinetic energy and potential energy a
wave also has a kinetic energy and it
can be thought of as one-half the rate
of change of the field over time squared
so if I took the derivative with respect
to time of Phi at any one point and then
I squared it multiplied by 1/2
integrated that over all the points in
space I would have the total kinetic
energy of the field now space is big
space is infinitely big r3 right the set
of all points ok so this is really the
kinetic energy at a point the kinetic
energy density the thing that we would
integrate over all space to get the
total kinetic energy but that's infinite
this is the finite thing so this is what
we care about there's also a new thing
we had kinetic energy for particles -
there's a new thing called the gradient
energy because there's a something that
a field can do in a particle can't which
is it can vary from point to point
in space not just for moment to moment
in time but the formula the sort of
pattern is exactly the same you
calculate the rate of change of the
field over space and you square that so
in other words if I have a field that is
very languorous ly changing from point
to point in space it has a low gradient
energy if it's vibrating really really
quickly in spin space forget about what
it's doing in time but it's just
changing very rapidly from point to
point it will have a lot of gradient
energy the gradient is the gratings just
yet another word for the slope of the
field how fast it's changing over space
and finally the field can also have its
own potential energy and in principle
that can be something very complicated
it can be a complicated landscape so for
every value of Phi the potential energy
is just the energy that doesn't depend
on how the field is changing in either
space or time it just depends on the
value of Phi but we said we're looking
at a very simple case of non interacting
free fields and in that case the
potential energy takes a very simple
form it is one-half times a parameter
which we'll call M Squared for right now
don't ask me why well I'll tell you why
in a second times the field value
squared so the potential energy unlike
the kinetic ingredient if you potential
energy is something that we choose when
we invent our theory the static energy
and gradient energy are basically fixed
for a scalar field theory potential
energy can be more complicated and when
we quantize it so we're choosing the
simplest possible thing one-half M
squared Phi squared basically right and
then what we're trying to get to is from
quantum fields to why we observe
particles and guess what this parameter
M that we choose when we invent our
theory will be the mass of the particles
so there is a parameter in how we define
our field theory that will eventually
tell us what the mass of the particles
is and also by the way k the wave vector
of a certain mode will be the momentum
I'm going to try once again I'm not
necessarily promising to be very good at
this but I'm going to try to reserve K
for the wave vector of a plane wave that
we're gonna use as a mode that decompose
into which field is decomposed and what
we're gonna do is analyze the field mode
by mode 1 mode at a time that's a good
thing to do but then when we make it
into particles particles will have their
own momentum the particles associated
with a plane wave of wave vector K will
have momentum K but usually what's going
to happen very quickly is that we're
gonna use all this machinery of plane
waves modes and all that stuff to let us
start talking about particles even
though we're doing quantum field theory
and then once we start talking about
particles I'm just gonna use the letter
P for their momentum just like we always
do when we talk about particles but it's
the same thing it's the same concept ok
so these are the different contributions
to the energy of a certain mode a
certain plane wave of our field ok again
this is just a simple way we can analyze
the field by breaking it up into these
modes it works especially well for non
interacting fields but it's a good
starting point even when we look at
interacting fields and then what we're
gonna do is we're gonna notice something
namely every single one of these
expressions we wrote down has the field
squared in some form right either the
field itself squared for the potential
energy or the rate of change of the
field for the kinetic energy or the rate
of the change of field over space for
the gradient energy so if we have two
plane waves that we consider and they're
the same except for different heights so
same wave vectors okay just the height
is different then the kinetic energy the
gradient energy and the potential energy
will all change proportional to the
height squared if you change the height
of the field then its kinetic energy
will have to change because it has
further to go when it's changing in time
if you change the height of the field
the gradient energy will change because
it is now moving more from point to
point because you increase the height of
the sine wave okay so what we notice is
that if you if we
that all the energies are proportional
loops to H squared where H is the height
of the sine wave the amplitude when you
call it that of the plane wave of the
mode that we're looking at so let's plot
this okay here is the height of a
certain mode here is the energy and it
doesn't matter whether we're thinking of
the kinetic the gradient or the
potential energy they all transform the
same way when we let the height go up
and it looks like this h squared okay
there's some proportionality constant
there but that doesn't matter to us what
matters is how the energy changes as we
change the height okay so I forget
actually whether we talked about this
concept but the idea of a parameter that
you can change and when you change it
the energy of the system just changes as
H squared on both sides positive H and
negative H this has a name that's a
famous name for a physical system it is
the simple harmonic oscillator it is the
one of the simplest physical systems you
can imagine thinking about it's the
spherical cow of quantum mechanics
simple harmonic oscillator because for
the simple reason we're gonna be able to
solve all the equations exactly for a
simple harmonic oscillator a more
physical example of this of a simple
harmonic oscillator is a wall with a
spring and on the spring there's a box I
think we talked about this particular
example and then the spring has a
strength K sorry that it's K again
that's what it is and the energy the
potential energy V of X if this is the
position X is 1/2 sorry
1/2 K squared times X minus X naught
squared where X naught is the
equilibrium point so the box moves
slides along frictionless surface it
wants to be as equilibrium
if you stretch the spring or compress
the spring the energy goes up as the
displacement squared that's an example
of a simple harmonic oscillator but what
we're saying here I mean this is pretty
awesome stuff I don't want to you know
undersell this because this is like
crucially crucially important what we've
done is taking a lot of simplifications
we've imagined a field that is non
interacting just a scalar field free
field and we've decomposed it into modes
right into plane waves with given wave
vectors and different heights and we've
said as the height changes the energy of
the mode changes as that height squared
a negative height is just we're
measuring it down in the sine wave
rather than up it's the same thing so
it's gonna be symmetric around zero and
in fact there's this good physical
argument that we gauge that the energy
is proportional to H squared so the
system of a single mode can be thought
of as a simple harmonic oscillator that
is very good news physics wise because
man people have analyzed simple harmonic
oscillators to death in fact you could
do this box that is attached to a spring
there are plenty of systems in quantum
mechanics when you first are in quantum
mechanics that act like simple harmonic
oscillators to a very good approximation
a hydrogen molecule so hydrogen atom is
a proton with one electron around it a
hydrogen molecule is two protons with
two electrons that keep them together
and if you imagine perturbing the
distance between those two protons it
acts just like a simple harmonic
oscillator so there's many many systems
in physics that had this simple harmonic
oscillator form and what we want to do
is quantize this harmonic oscillator
okay so remember what we're doing here
we have the wave function for our field
but we're decomposing is that the right
word to use yet decomposing our field
into a sum of modes we're expressing it
as a sum of the particular modes and so
we can look at the wave function of each
mode separately and then sort of combine
them at the end of the day so let's look
at the wave function of a mode single
mode that means a single plane wave with
a fixed wave vector and a fixed height
and all that so this is saw
of Phi and this is a single modify so it
is parametrized by H the height of the
mode and K the wave vector that's all
you need to know to tell me what exactly
mode I am talking about and a wave
function is gonna tell me the
probability of observing that mode to
have a different height different wave
vector okay in fact actually this is
probably I'm realizing this is probably
not the best way to say it
the mode is fixed by the value of K so
let's write the mode itself as Phi sub K
okay so Phi sub K is a mode in other
words a plane wave with a certain wave
vector in a certain size of the wave
vector and direction in which it's
pointing and that field configuration
corresponding to that mode only depends
on the value of H I think that's the
better way of saying given the wave
vector we know what the plane wave is
doing we just don't know how big its
deviations are up and down how much the
field is actually oscillating that is
what is fixed by this height H H is the
maximum value of oscillation of the
field up and down so even though we have
this complicated field Phi is function
of X everywhere by looking at it mode by
mode and we realize that if you tell me
what the wave vector is the only thing
that varies to tell me what the mode is
doing is its height I have turned this
complicated wave function of the whole
set of field configurations into a wave
function of a single number H right and
furthermore I know what the energy of H
looks like as H changes the energy goes
like H squared it's a simple harmonic
oscillator so this is a quantum
mechanical system that I know how to
deal with and I say quantum mechanical
because this actually I should have said
this a long time ago there are people
who think that there's quantum mechanics
and that quantum field theory is somehow
another theory passed quantum mechanics
ok that is not the way of thinking about
it you
nonrelativistic quantum mechanics and
you also have quantum mechanics of point
particles
you also have quantum mechanics of
fields and the most popular quantum
field theories are relativistic quantum
fields we're not gonna worry about the
fact that they're relativistic but these
quantum fields are compatible with the
rules of special relativity which we
talked about in the spacetime video okay
so my point is that when we do quantum
field theory we're not replacing quantum
mechanics we're doing a version of
quantum mechanics nevertheless some
people including myself will sometimes
lapse into a lingo which uses the phrase
quantum mechanics to mean the quantum
mechanics of a particle or a finite
number of degrees of freedom as opposed
to a field that has a degrees of freedom
at every point an infant number of
degrees of freedom okay by taking our
field writing it as a sum of modes and
thinking about only the height of each
mode we've taken this complicated
quantum field theory problem and turn it
into a set of very very simple problems
because every mode just a function of
one variable H and we can do quantum
mechanics of that single variable so
let's do that although I do that I mean
I'm going to tell you what the result is
I'm not really gonna like solve the
equation all of its glory let me just
redraw the plot of the energy okay so
this is a value of H and this is the
energy of the mode so this is the energy
of Phi sub K as a function of H and it
looks like this it is a parabola it goes
like h squared so remember when we
talked about the electron in the
hydrogen atom we said that even though
the electron had a wave function the
wave function was perfectly smooth you
want for physics reasons I think I
explained this best in the Q&A video for
the quantum mechanics lecture rather
than in the actual quantum mechanics
video itself look at the Q&A video you
want the wave function to go to zero at
infinity far away from the nucleus of
the atom there's a competition where the
electron wants to be close to the
nucleus but also the wave function of
the electron if it varies too quickly if
it's gradient is too large then that
costs a lot of energy so the minimum
energy state is one where the way
function of the electron is bunched up
near the nucleus and it goes to zero
there is a next highest energy where the
wave function electron varies a little
bit wiggles once but nevertheless it
still goes to zero far away from the
nucleus in all directions and this is a
very common phenomenon it is exactly
like as we keep saying a string where
you tie down the two ends of the string
and then you pluck it right there is a
lowest note that you can get the
fundamental of that and there are
overtones or harmonics from that which
have more than one wavelength in them
okay so that is the origin of
discreteness in quantum mechanics is not
because you start with discrete
ingredients you start with this field
and you quantize it and get a wave
function of it but when you solve the
equations you find that the solutions
come in a discrete set that's also true
for the simple harmonic oscillator in
fact it's easier to see in the case of
the simple harmonic oscillator you can
solve this and guess what because the
energy is going towards infinity up here
if you go up high enough there's never a
point where the energy stops growing
okay the energy it cost more and more
energy for the height of the wave to be
bigger and bigger right so if you want
to look at modes of this toy problem
this thing up whimper this is just one
little part of our big problem our big
problems quantizing the field we have
chopped that big problem down into a set
of little problems this problem is
quantizing a single variable the height
of the sine wave it's energy goes as H
squared and if you want finite energy
solutions to the quantum mechanical
problem of just this one mode those wave
functions for H better go to zero at
infinity because as you go to higher and
higher Heights it costs more and more
energy potentially an infinite amount if
you never come down it will cost you
anything amount of energy so there are a
discrete set of solutions to this
equation there is a lowest energy
solution a next higher energy solution a
higher energy solution after that and in
fact one of the reasons why the simple
harmonic oscillator is nice is because
the energies are exactly
evenly spaced between each other the
difference between lowest energy and
next highest is the same so if you plot
the energy levels here's energy level n
here is N equals 0 n equals 1 and equals
2 N equals 3 and it's the same distance
in energy ok so to go from one energy
solution to the next highest is an equal
change every single time and what I mean
by this I visualize this I should have
drawn this here is the form of the wave
function of lowest energy call it size 0
of H this is really sigh of Phi of K of
H but just keep in mind that we're
fixing what K is and we can just write
it as Phi of H ok and so this is the
lowest energy mode it has an energy
which I'll tell you later but right now
it's the lowest energy mode and then
there is one that is next higher in
energy that looks like this sigh one of
H and then there is one next higher
energy after that this green good yeah
green is good like this this is sy 2 of
H etc the point is I said it before go
and keep saying it because it's just
crucially important we start with like
the smoothest thing in the world this
field that is stretching out through all
space and we have a wave function of
that field but then when we look at the
lowest energy state the field can be in
it's a sum of modes and every mode will
be in its lowest energy state we can
also have states of the field of
slightly higher energy by taking one of
those modes and bumping it up into its
next highest energy state ok and there's
a discrete difference in energy between
those two possibilities and the number
the amount of energy that you change by
is you increase what mode you look what
what energy state you're looking at is
the same every time ok so there is an
interpretation of
I should let me just say one other fact
about this the pinning down here of the
mo of the modes I keep saying modes
depending on the wave functions these
all go to 0 at minus infinity and plus
infinity ok it's a little bit different
than the electron the electron in the
nucleus in the in atom was had a wave
function that was nonzero near the
nucleus and went to 0 a large physical
distance away from the nucleus this is a
more conceptual thing so I'm asking you
you know this is not an easy thing I get
I'm asking you to bear with me for a
little bit of a conceptual leap here
this is the wave function is going to 0
as H increases so this is a wave
function of a mode parametrized by its
height what it's saying is we don't know
when we measure this mode how high it's
going to be what the height of that
particular mode is going to be because
quantum mechanics right because all we
can do is predict the probability these
colorful lines that we've drawn are the
wave functions for different states the
mode could be in and we would square
them to get the probability of observing
the mode to have that height and what
we're saying is because we want minimum
energy States because we just start with
zero energy and then build from there
all of the modes will have the property
that there's very very very little
probability of ever measuring the mode
to have too much height because that
would cost too much energy so they're
pinned down at large values of the
height of the mode not at large values
of distance from the nucleus but the
math is the same now ok now is the big
reveal
there is basically an interpretation of
this and I wish I could do a better job
at explaining why this is a good
interpretation but it is a good
interpretation and maybe I've justified
it enough the real thing is that you
know there's this constant difference in
energy between these different energy
levels the interpretation is size 0 the
lowest energy state of the mode that
we're looking at can be thought of as a
collection of 0 particles it is the
lowest energy state it's the vacuum
state it's something
that is just there there's nothing
happening there's nothing moving around
it's the lowest energy state you can be
in there is a state that has slightly
more energy and that we interpret as a
state containing a single particle there
is a state that has slightly more energy
than that side too and that can be
interpreted as a state that has two
particles in it and this goes on there's
an infinite Tower of states cyan which
you can think of as having n particles
why does that make sense well there's a
cheap and easy way of having it make
sense I mean think about the these are
all for a single mode for it so for a
single wave vector so for a single
momentum of the particle if I give you
one particle in a state just classically
one particle with a certain momentum
it'll have a certain energy if I give
you two particles with exactly the same
momentum the same kinds of particles it
will have twice that energy and if I
give you three particles with the same
momentum the same kind of particle you
know three electrons moving the same
direction three times the energy so
these equally spaced energy levels are
at least consistent with the idea that
we can interpret them as describing
different numbers of particles now it
goes way beyond that you can actually do
you can dig into this and you can do an
exact correlation an exact map between
the wavefunction not just of the height
but also of the position in space you
can make way packets by superimposing
different modes on top of each other and
find that if you have like a bunch of
different modes all of them are in their
N equals 1 state all of them are
supposed to be you know one particle
that's just a complicated wave function
for a single particle it acts exactly
like that okay this is why quantum field
theory is a theory of particles because
you can think of the theory you can
think of the individual fields as being
described by a set of different modes
and the modes because of this harmonic
oscillator kind of behavior that it
costs energy for the height of the mode
to be big have discrete sets of
solutions
to the Schrodinger equation with
discrete energies that are equally
spaced and therefore can be thought of
as describing different particles now
you want to be more than that obviously
you want to do more than that you want
to describe why these modes when they
hit a cloud chamber will leave a
trajectory okay and that comes down to a
different feature you know we can't
answer that question at this level
because we assumed from the start that
we had a non interacting feel this is
not an electron the electron has to
interact with the cloud chamber to leave
a track behind so to answer the question
of why particles leave tracks is a bit
trickier and the answer is of course
because the answer relies on the fact
that the interactions between the
electron and the rest of the world are
local in space the electron only
interacts with things that are right
next to it that's why it leaves a track
we talked a little bit about that back
in the time when we were talking about
force and energy in action and we talked
about momentum versus position and
velocities and the Hamiltonian all that
stuff it's locality that makes things
look particle like this story just
justifies why you can start with
something as wavy as you can get right
the wave function of a set of fields and
it can be interpreted as a set of
discrete particles so in fact that is
the punch line and I'll just write it
again because it's worth saying one
quantum field it can be thought of in
the right circumstances and these
circumstances are right so far but
they'll be more complicated ones but can
be thought of as a superposition of
different numbers of particles
in fact this is one way to invent
quantum field theory we invented quantum
field theory by saying let's say we have
a field that's quantize it you can also
invent quantum field theory by saying
let's say we have many particles and try
to come up with a convenient
mathematical way of characterizing all
the particles at once and what you do is
end up inventing a quantum field it's
the same thing so by superposition I
mean you know we decomposed our
wavefunction of quantum fields into wave
individual wave functions of different
modes but the real whole shabang the big
thing
sigh of phi of x is a superposition of
all those different modes and every mode
can be a superposition of these
different energy states ok so not only
does this particular quantum field it
not only could it describe one particle
or two particles or three particles it
can describe a set of particles you know
how many there are
when you observe it there's a
probability that you'll see three
particles or twelve particles or
whatever that's the beauty of quantum
field theory and in fact you can observe
it at different times and the number of
particles can change I'm not going to
justify this but there is a there's a
folk theorem which means it's not really
a theorem but there are good arguments
in favor of it that says that if you
want quantum mechanics and special
relativity and you want to be able to
change the number of particles change
number of particles the only way to do
that is in a quantum field theory QFT
quantum field theory so there's a
justification for why things need to be
quantum field theories that's the only
way to obey all these cherrish
principles all at once ok did I get that
right yes I think I got that right so
that's why we have we start with quantum
fields we get particles it's it's at
least again I didn't justify it all the
way but I tried to make it seem like a
plausible thing now we're not done we're
not done with quantum field theory
we have a long to-do list okay we're not
gonna do it all today we'll we'll do
some of it later on we'll do a lot of it
but you know quantum field theory is
hard like come on field theory really is
the combination of hardest and most
important subject in physics is what I
would say you know you can argue that
you know some specific very technical
field of high-temperature
superconductivity or string theory or
whatever is harder than quantum field
theory because we don't know what the
rules are etc but those are only
interesting to some people who are
specialists in those fields quantum
field theory is central to modern
physics and it's really hard in part
it's really hard because there's a lot
of infinite quantities you know the
dimensionality of various Hilbert spaces
is infinite as we'll see there's a
famous problem in quantum field theory
with an infinite answer to certain well
posed questions what is the probability
that these two electrons bounce off of
each other if you calculate it sloppily
you'll get an infinite answer and that's
bad this is the problem of renormalizing
the infinities okay so there's a lot of
subtleties that go into quantum field
theory but it's crucially important it's
absolutely central right now quantum
field theory is the best way we having
we have of describing nature at its
deepest level so the hardness is worth
it we should we should do it so what
we'll have to do and not necessarily
disorder is imagine that there are
different types of fields so we
mentioned that already so there are not
only scalar fields there are vector
fields there are tensor fields like the
gravitational field I'll explain what
that means and there are even spinner
fields which are not vectors or tensors
things like the electron neutrino etc
fermions as they are called the matter
particles are made of spinner fields
well we'll get into that don't worry so
different types involve the scalar oops
scalar fields like the Higgs vector
fields like electricity and magnetism
now the cognoscenti in the audience will
know that secretly the electric and
magnetic fields are not vector fields
after all they're both part of a single
tensor field we'll get to that and it's
worse than that because there is a
vector fee
from which they both get derived the
vector potential field all I'm just you
know shouting out to the people who know
what is going on here the electric and
magnetic fields come from an honest
vector field even though they're not
honest vector fields themselves
sometimes they're usually in particle
physics these come from gauge fields and
that has to do with a certain symmetry
that the fields have and we'll try to
explain where that symmetry comes from
and why it's important in the forces of
nature and then you also have Fermi on
fields spinners spinners spelled in a
weird way o RS not it's one n ORS not
two N's ers not a set of things that
spin but spinners is the mathematical
formalism and these are matter particles
right electrons quarks etc so there's a
enormous amount of richness in quantum
field theory because there can be many
different types of fields and then the
richness continues because you have to
let them interact right and the way that
you do that is the simplest way this
sort of first step in learning how to
let them interact is by thinking about
Fineman diagrams so what I did here all
of this stuff is to sort of justify why
under the right circumstances you can
think of a single quantum field as a
superposition of a collection of
particles and then finally diagrams sort
of take that license and really put it
to good use
they say good let's just do particle
physics let's imagine we have a certain
set of particles to start and it does
quantum mechanics the particles interact
and they evolve into a superposition of
different numbers of particles outgoing
so you might have for example two
electrons
II - II - and the Feynman diagram will
say that they scatter off of each other
time is going this way by exchanging a
photon photons are usually denoted gamma
the Greek letter gamma in particle
physics okay
so we'll have to understand what's going
on here how you can use this cute little
picture to actually calculate the
probability of this kind of interaction
happening and then we have to talk about
you know that messy set of issues that I
mentioned infinities renormalization
some theories can be renormalized some
can't it's an issue etc ok so there's a
lot of conceptual issues that we have to
get on with there is one thing I should
probably ease on is an hour of my
computer telling me it's been an hour
we're not gonna talk about any of these
things today I'm going to end the video
but there's one thing I really do want
to talk about because it is not talked
about in most discussions of quantum
field theory but cosmologists care about
it a lot and that is the issue of the
energy of the vacuum so in ordinary
quantum mechanics you have a certain
number of particles and that number of
particles remains fixed right in quantum
field theory when you really have a
field you can interpret that as
particles but the number of particles
comes and goes it turns out that in
quantum field theory even the zero
energy state even the state of lowest
possible energy is still an interesting
place so the vacuum in quantum field
theory is the lowest energy state and
the reason why it's interesting is
because you still have at every point in
space there's still you know the quantum
mechanical version of Phi of X right
there's still some quantum state for the
field that is filling all of space and
indeed the lowest energy state in
quantum field theory is a superposition
of the lowest energy States
Oh
all those modes right so I can take
every single mode of my quantum field
which is purely hypothetical right like
remember classical field has a
configuration a quantum field has a wave
function over the set of all
configurations so even if we're in the
lowest energy state we don't just say
the field is zero we say the field has a
wave function if you observe the quantum
field even in the vacuum you can get any
answer there will be a nonzero
possibility of you getting any
particular value for the field
if you observe it because the wave
function doesn't ever go exactly to zero
okay it goes to pretty close to zero oh
it eventually goes to zero when you get
to infinity but you never get to
infinity so at any one point you have
actually that was that was mistaken
infinity in energy at any one point in
space you have a value that of the field
Phi of X that you could always get in
principle you can't get Phi equals
infinity but you get the same answer at
every point in space okay
so even the vacuum is an interesting
place in quantum field theory and you
say well ok it's the lowest energy state
this is state with zero particles right
in quantum field theory you have the
vacuum the lowest energy state you have
States with one particle you have States
with two particles etc the set of all
those things is the set of states that
the system can be in that the thing can
be in why would the vacuum be
interesting well you see look at this
yellow line here conceptualize that
maybe I can just I always am slightly
nervous when I try to cut and paste in
this program this is not the program I
usually use copy good what are the
chances I can paste it on I think I did
this once before successfully paste huh
it worked
I could do that 20 more times in the
course of these videos I will always be
pleasantly surprised okay the point is
for a classical particle in a potential
like this let me see if I can find yet
another color to use here's blue okay
so here's a classical particle I'm
comparing a classical particle in a
potential to a quantum wave function in
exactly the same potential so I'm not
sure how visible this blue is but the
classical particle now it's not visible
at all is it I'll use white again
minimum energy of the classical particle
in a potential V of X equals let's call
it for future reference sake 1/2 Omega
squared x squared okay I know that this
picture I wrote H but we're just doing
the general idea of a quadratic
potential of an x squared potential
that's the simple harmonic oscillator at
its essence so what is the minimum
energy state well kinetic energy of the
particle can be 0 the particle can just
sit there doesn't have to move and the
potential energy of the particle can
also be 0 it can be at the minimum at x
equals 0 so total energy can also be 0
the minimum energy of a classical
particle in this potential is 0 I'm
belaboring a point that you are not
surprised at all to hear but look at
that yellow curve there right that
yellow curve is changing that's the
minimum energy quantum wave function in
the same potential but it's not just a
point sitting at the origin right it has
some support everywhere sort of spreads
out a little bit so we can calculate the
energy of that profile you know we I
didn't over here you know when we're
talking about those I said that they're
equally spaced but I didn't tell you
by how much they're spaced I didn't tell
you what the first one was so that's
math you just do it you plug into the
Schrodinger equation it's still a
Schrodinger equation even in quantum
field theory there's a version of the
Schrodinger equation don't believe
people who tell you the Schrodinger
equation applies only to nonrelativistic
particles the equation Schrodinger
himself wrote down does in fact apply
only to nonrelativistic particles but
it's easy to generalize the Schrodinger
equation is H sy equals I D by D psi the
Hamiltonian acting on the wave function
is I there's an H bar in there that is I
set equal to 1 times the time derivative
of sy and that's true for any theory
that you have you just have to give me
what H is what the Hamiltonian is it
works equally well for quantum field
theory as for anything else ok so what
is the energy of this quantum thing
the quantum thing is in yellow here so
the energy of the lowest energy state in
quantum theory quantum minimum energy
yeah try to squeeze things in so my
handwriting is becoming less good well
you work it out it equals 1/2 let's call
it anot 1/2 H bar Omega where Omega is
this parameter that appeared in the
potential right there so it's not zero
it's greater than zero what make is a
positive number
ok there there's a minimum energy in the
quantum theory that is different than
the classical theory and in fact it's a
little bit it goes beyond that I can
actually tell you what the answer is for
the other energy states the energy for n
particles equals n plus one-half times H
bar Omega so what is it that's the
energy of all these different wave
functions sy 0 sy 1 sy - they're all sy
n where n plus 1/2 times H bar Omega is
the energy so the zero energy state has
1/2 H bar Omega
the next
highest state has an energy three-halves
h-bar Omega 2 particle has 5 halves H
bar Omega etc okay it almost never
matters what the energy of the lowest
energy state is what matters is the
difference in energy between one excited
state as we call them
there's the lowest energy state the
ground state and then any other state is
called an excited state it's excited to
be having more energy than the ground
state the difference is in energy U
which in this case is just some multiple
of h-bar Omega
those matter because you can see them if
you have a particle or some system that
is an excited state and it undergoes a
transition to a lower energy state let's
say by emitting a photon much like an
electron in an atom goes to a lower
energy state than emits a photon then
you can measure the change in energy the
difference in energy between two states
so usually in physics the ground state
energy itself doesn't matter after all
we just took this potential and let's
say we added a constant to it plus C we
raise the whole potential up or down it
doesn't change anything at all anything
measurable except and there's one thing
that it changes I'll erase that here
just because one thing that it changes
is the energy of empty space remember
this is supposed to be the real world
and this is saying there are fields in
empty space those fields could have
energy so let's imagine you did the
following thing let's imagine you set
the classical energy of empty space
to zero why well because we said so
that's that's the reality of
justification we're imagining that's
what you chose to do the field the
quantum field is a superposition of an
infinite number of harmonic oscillators
the modes of the quantum field the plane
waves right that's what we said the
quantum field this is just a general
fact the quantum field can be thought of
there's a superposition of all these
different modes you can put every single
one of those modes into its lowest
energy state but all those lowest energy
states still have energy even though
they're the lowest energy this is the
extra quantum bit over and above the
lowest classical energy so quantum
mechanics QM contributes an infinite
energy to empty space that sounds bad
it is bad this is known as the
cosmological constant problem Einstein
remember Einstein
maybe not remembered maybe never heard
the story but back in 1917 Einstein
already had general relativity he
figured that out in late 1915 1916 and
he was applying it to the universe as a
whole and he was looking for a solution
to his equations that had you know stars
distributed equally throughout the
universe which is kind of prescient it
wasn't obvious that that's how things
were but now we know that distributing
galaxies equally throughout the universe
is pretty good approximation and what he
found is that the universe would either
expand or contract those are the two
possible solutions there was no solution
where the universe just sat there static
and he asked his astronomer friends is
the universe static and they said yes
because that's what they thought in 1917
it was 1920s where Hubble discovered
that the universe is actually expanding
so Einstein figured out a way to add a
new term to his equation for general
relativity which he called the
cosmological constant and it sort of
pushed things apart and it created
balance the matter was trying to pull
things together because much class was
pushing things apart so he could find a
solution to his equations it which in
which the universe is neither expanding
or contracting the so-called Einstein
static universe now we now later
reinterpreted Einsteins cosmos with
constant as a measure of the energy
density of empty space and I assigned
once he realized universe was expanding
he was like ah that was a bad idea get
rid of the cosmos what constant nowadays
we've discovered it we discovered the
universe is accelerating in 1998 strong
numbers discovered that and we
attributed to the cosmological constant
the problem is the cosmological concept
on the one hand is just a free parameter
you can pick it you can set it to be
whatever you want if you're God and
setting up the rules of the universe you
can make it whatever you want but it
seems like the difference between your
classical theory and quantum theory is
infinitely big when it comes to the
cosmological constant so whatever the
observed cause Marvell constant is
here's the logic that people go through
and we don't know this logic is right in
fact somehow it has to be wrong but
here's the logic the logic is wherever
you get the cosmos will constant from
you can always think of it as a
classical piece plus a quantum piece and
naively if you figure out the quantum
piece it's the sum of the zero point
energies the vacuum energies of an
infinite number of modes an infinite
number of simple harmonic oscillators so
literally at every point in space you
should have an infinite energy density
just from the quantum contribution now
you can make the classical contribution
equal to minus infinity you could
exactly cancel it right but there's no
reason to there's nothing special or
good about zero cosmological constant
and now things have gotten worse because
in 1998 we discovered we don't have zero
cosmological constant we have a small
but nonzero value that's crazy we have
no reason to think that we should have a
small but nonzero value of the cosmos
bullet constant if it were zero like
when I was a graduate student everyone
thought it was
zero and we said well we don't know why
but there must be some symmetry that
makes the cosmological constant exactly
zero and people say well let's look for
that symmetry or some dynamical
mechanism or something like that when we
discovered it in 1998 that there was a
nonzero cosmological constant but there
was nowhere close to the quantum
mechanical contribution by itself
everyone is now more puzzled than they
ever were so the solutions the search
for solutions to the cosmological
constant problem are ongoing
not to get too far out of what we're
supposed to be talking about here but
the here's how bad it is the best
solution on the market into why the
cosmological constant is small is the
anthropic principle if you imagine there
are different parts of the universe
where the cosmological constant takes on
different values than if it were really
big infinitely big or even finite but
really really big you wouldn't be able
to form a galaxy right it would just
blow everything apart the cost marshal
constant either if it's large and
positive pushes matter apart at a
tremendous rate or if it's large and
negative causes the universe tree
collapse very very quickly in order to
get a universe that lasts long enough
for galaxies to form but doesn't blow
them apart with a super fast accelerated
expansion the cosmological constant has
to be small so if you live in a
multiverse where the cosmological
constant takes on different values in
different places we living complicated
organic beings who rely on a long-lived
universe with galaxies in it to exist
would only ever find ourselves in
regions where the cosmos are constant is
small I'm not saying that I agree with
that answer or that I like it but it's
on the table as a possible answer and in
fact I can say in my judgment it's
better than any of the alternative
answers as of right now so really what
that means is not that the anthropic
principle in the multiverse are right
but then we don't know why the
cosmological constant is small and it's
a very interesting way to get at the
kinds of problems that come up when you
try to marry quantum field theory with
gravity of course we're talking about
the biggest ideas in the universe so
we're gonna get to some of the ways you
can try to marry quantum field theory
with gravity eventually first we have to
do a little bit
or understanding and quantum field
theory itself our journey is not yet
over